well first of all i really salute
caroline next i've got a lot of respect
for her um she and i have worked
together on many things and i think that
she has shown great leadership here
she's chair of the women and equalities
committee she's doing work that is to
help women across the country and by
coming forward and being prepared to
speak out against
to make an allegation of sexual
harassment and it is sexual harassment
it may even be sexual assault obviously
that's to be confirmed um but you know
what caroline said is really important
because it shows other women that we can
speak out and that we should speak out i
salute her i support her and i very much
hope that this is properly investigated
and urgently so what should that
investigation look like well i mean it
could be a criminal matter it very much
depends and part of this will depend on
what caroline wants to do i certainly
think that the conservative party has a
duty of care towards all its mps and all
their staff of course and to investigate
if this is um something that may have
there may be a pattern of behaviour here
is there something that other victims
may have experienced now that's what we
found with the independent complaints
and grievance process in parliament is
that when one victim speaks up about a
particular person on the parliamentary
estate where they've experienced sexual
harassment or bullying others often say
yes that's happened to me too and that's
because very very rarely is there is it
a one-off incident in my experience i
used to work with abusive men before i
became an mp it's very rarely one-off so
when in this step when an incident is
established of course this has to be
investigated very often there will
either be other victims or other
incidents and i really hope that the
process that the conservative party
employs allows for other people to come
forward if if there are other people of
course didn't happen on the
parliamentary it did not
saying absolutely nothing to do with us
it's he's not an mp yes and that's of
course you know that's that's relevant
but they do also have a duty of care
towards their own mps and i think that
that should be part of it that should be
part of what they're doing is supporting
caroline but i i support caroline
whatever she chooses to do on this and i
think she's been very brave very
courageous and shown women that up with
this we will not put why should we have
to put up with any sort of sexual
harassment in this day and age it's also
monstrous that there is this widespread
culture of acceptance which we know and
this is going beyond this particular
allegation that there's so much sexual
harassment still taking place in in our
nightclubs university students have told
me recently about things that are taking
place for them when they go out on a
night out and that there's an awful lot
to tackle and i think we need to tackle
this culture of sexism and misogyny
that's still around sadly it breaks my
heart actually because i've been working
on this for so long to see that young
women are still having to put up with
some of the things that i thought should
be consigned to history years ago we
should say of course absolutely we
should say that stanley johnson says he
has a recollection of this incident he
has nothing to say he does indeed say
that he doesn't know who caroline knope
says just to so the lawyers are happy um
as far as hearing from the home
secretary overnight she has talked about
what's been happening in liverpool um as
a result of dysfunctional asylum system
well that's extraordinary isn't it i
mean the tory party has actually been in
charge of the asylum system for the past
11 years
i did put that to anne marie trevelyan
who was here for the government this
morning she says
not under this uh home secretary's watch
you have to look further back to sadie
javid and as a result pretty patel is
doing a much better job well that's a
very unedifying tory on tory fight isn't
it it's still a conservative party
that's been running the country for the
last 11 years they've been running the
asylum system and over the course of
successive home secretary since i've
been an mp i've noticed a serious
deterioration in the adherence to their
own service standards it used to be when
i first came in in 2015 you could on
behalf of a constituent who had applied
for asylum at least get information out
of the home office in a timely manner
and more often than not they would stick
to their service standard of making a
decision within six months now that's in
everybody's interests making a fair and
proper decision within six months is in
the interest of those who are concerned
about whether or not these are asylum
seekers with a good cause and those of
us who've worked with many asylum
seekers and know that the majority and
the refugee council's research has shown
this overnight majority of people
arriving here do have a valid claim to
be heard now we are a country that
respects human rights and we should be
proud of that if pretty patel wants to
reform the asylum system she shouldn't
start by punishing people who are trying
to flee um desperate circumstances and
unfortunately that's going to be the
effect of her nationality and borders
bill there are different ways of doing
things one of the things we can do is
increase our support for what's called
resettlement that's where we take people
on safe and legal routes from war zones
from near to conflict zones and provide
them with the appropriate assessment in
country and then support to resettle
here and so they don't have to make
dangerous journeys it's hollow words i'm
afraid from pretty patella she's talking
about cracking down on traffickers or
making sure people can't get here on
small boats she doesn't seem to realize
that the way to do that is to make sure
that we have proper support to help
people fleeing desperate circumstances
on safe and legal routes and not punish
those who get here because they're
desperate very often her current
proposals are not fit for purpose we
would do things differently my viewers
would say some of them in response would
say yeah but some of these people coming
are terrorists and they are blowing up
people in the united states and that's
why we should have a proper system and
you know i don't disagree we need a
robust system of course we do and there
are good assessment processes in place
unfortunately what i've seen my my
experience with the home office is that
unfortunately it's woefully inadequate
it's been hollowed out in terms of
staffing i think if pretty patel wants
to make the system work better she
should make sure that there is adequate
staffing that processes are adhered to
that the assessments are done in a
timely manner that's not what's
happening at the moment and i think she
needs to look to her own department
rather than fling stones at others how
much does it help to conflate the two
issues of um a dysfunctional asylum
system and what happened in liverpool we
heard from the mayor of liverpool
yesterday and he says there is online
hate and he is doing everything he can
to try to unite the people of liverpool
it's a very difficult time
it is a difficult time and i salute the
people of liverpool and the emergency
services and all those who've been
involved in in responding to this awful
awful incident
and and i do think that liverpool the
people of liverpool are very strong and
they will come together and they will
unite and terrorism isn't per se caused
by asylum seeking there are many routes
into terrorism we have to look at what's
causing the hate and division in our
society there are many causes they all
need to be taken on board and i'm glad
that the mayor of liverpool and others
in liverpool have spoken out so strongly
on the need for unity and coming
together and uniting against hate mps
are going to be voting later on on
second jobs or um
starting to vote um on what that
actually means i've got lots of
questions like what are reasonable
limits is that ours or is it
remuneration who decides what is a
second job who's going to be in charge
of any uh appeals uh process and why is
all of this not clear given that you're
voting on it today well why does it take
any order i want great okay so um what
is the second job uh we've put forward
some proposals that at the very least
and that's what we're going to vote on
today these paid um political strategy
consultancy advisory roles mp should not
be allowed to do that now this is not
new we're not new to this we actually
put forward this proposal in 2015 before
even i became an mp and the tory
government i'm afraid to say voted it
down if they'd voted with us they might
not been in such a mess over the owen
patterson affair i'm afraid so that's
the first thing that's already been
defined by the committee on standards of
public life they are an independent
public body whose job it is to
scrutinize not just what mps do but all
public life and cart with appropriate
recommendations to strengthening the
system so that's the first thing um
there are a lot of questions there i
think the who should adjudicate um there
is already
as i said the committee on standards in
public life which sets up and reviews
those systems we also have the
ministerial code and now that needs
strengthening and i think that's who
should you be able to appeal to if you
don't well we already have an appeals
process for mps and this has been one of
the myth-making of the services yes i
know and that's just just not true
that's just simply not true the appeals
process is you start with the the
independent standards commissioner she
investigates makes her recommendation
that's put to the standards committee
they have an appeals process that's
above and beyond courts of law so all
these these faux outrage comments that
we've had from tory mps over the last
few weeks is really willfully ignorant
of the process we already have the
standards committee has lay members on
it it has a it has a balance between lay
members and parliamentarians it's
balanced between the parties and what
they do is review the evidence take more
evidence hear from more witnesses they
allow the the person appealing which in
this case is owen patterson for instance
to make more representations to them
they consider all of that and then they
determine whether or not they want to
uphold the standards commissioners
findings or not and very often they
disagree that has happened in this case
they found that the evidence was
absolutely massive yeah they did um have
you got a second job i do not i mean i
consider being an mp of vocation uh in
my time as an mp i mean
well i i i think that for an awful lot
of mps we we consider this something
that we are 24 hours a day seven days a
week now there are occasions when
certain colleagues and i absolutely
salute them for this for instance you
know rosenna allen khan i don't think
anybody really thinks the problem with
sleeves is working in an nhs a e
especially during the covid crisis you
know nadia whittam went back to her old
job as a care assistant when it was
needed there's tory mps who are doctors
and nurses people who are army
reservists i don't think anyone thinks
that's the problem here i think people
know where the problem is and it's these
paid basically lobbying jobs effectively
where mps instead of doing what is best
for their constituents and the country
we make a vow to the country
are putting the interests of private
companies who've paid them before their
constituents before the company that
cannot be right and our motion today
would settle that very clearly we didn't
it didn't come out of nowhere we've
already put it to the cut to the tory
government six years ago the committee
on standards of public life recommended
it three years ago it's time to put this
right i hope the tories vote with us
today